sauver la dernière usine de production
de papier 100% recyclé en france le 28
avril
les employés de l'usiné de la chapelle
darblay en normandie
entouré de syndicats et d'associations
environnementales ont occupé une partie
du port de la rapée à paris devant le
ministère de l'économie jusqu'en 2019 le
site industriel absorbé 350 mille tonnes
de papier par an correspondant au tri de
24 millions de personnes notamment les
habitants de l'île de france
mais en septembre 2019 son propriétaire
le géant finlandais upm a décidé de
vendre ce fleuron du recyclage français
et de le démanteler
c'est un accord avec un repreneur
n'était pas signée c'était sans compter
sur la combativité de ses salariés qui
défendent leur usine et ont obtenu de la
maintenir en état de marche jusqu'en
juin 2021
depuis 19 mois ils frappent aux portes
pour favoriser la reprise de l'activité
papetière jusqu'au bout on mettra en
fait la pression en bon niveau on mettra
chapelle darblay tout en haut pour que
ce dossier puisse aboutir
ils ont été appuyés par de nombreux
parlementaires politique et même par le
maire de rouen
si on ferme le site on se retrouve à
faire quoi va brûler du papier à enfouir
du papier c'est complètement absurde
en 2020 le ministre de l'économie lui
même bruno le maire avait promis de les
aider nous pouvons retrouver une
solution de reprise pour la chapelle
darblay une reprise est possible et nous
continuons à y travailler mais il manque
une annonce officielle
les salariés de chapelle darblay ont
obtenu une entrevue avec la secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
agnès pannier rue nash et le jour du
rassemblement nous sommes entendus avec
la ministre pour que l'offre ferme soit
avant tout papetière et que le que
l'appel chapelle darblay puisse
redémarrer sur avec ses machines avec
tous ces ascètes mais pas si simple
civil briffaud délégué syndical cgt
redoute qu'un autre projet soit
favorisée par upm pour éliminer la
compétition en france
le groupe finlandais a déjà détruit ces
machines à papier par le passé le 6
septembre 2010 elle surprend un peu
l'histoire ils ont annoncé fermer la
chapelle darblay pour des causes de
compétitivité donc ça veut tout dire ça
veut dire qu'ils ne veulent plus de
machines à papier dans le coin que ce
soit chapelle darblay que ce soit
important pour un tiers des français
grand groupe upm en finlande s'en fout
littéralement la petite chapelle darblay
l'intérêt des français c'est pas son
problème
par contre c'est le nôtre on s'inquiète
énormément des types d'offres qui
peuvent être déposés il y en a plusieurs
qui sont déposés même s'ils sont à 90
on a appris que un projet d'hydrogène à
l'arrivée si demain on fait venir un
projet hydrogène en grande masse ça veut
dire qu'il ya plus de machines à papier
tout est complètement rasé on éventre la
chaudière et la chapelle darblay c'est
terminé et par ailleurs les velléités du
gouvernement vis-à-vis de la transition
écologique plaident en faveur d'un
maintien de l' usine
si on veut parler transition faisant là
réellement vous avez une plateforme
amazon à côté qui va mobiliser beaucoup
d'emballages avoir une cartonnerie à
côté ça paraît pas incohérent
donc trouvons les moyens de créer c'est
cette dynamique de proximité cette
dynamique circulaire dans la
consommation et dans le recyclage
s'il faut les chercher monsieur macro on
ira le faire mais il faut maintenant
s'intéressa chapelle l'armée ne pas la
laisser se terrent fait régner la date
limite de dépôt des offres est fixée au
14 mai l'épilogué proche le gouvernement
sera-t-il imposer la poursuite d'une
activité que salariés et politiques de
tous bords appellent de leurs voeux